BRENDON HARRINGTON:
We talked before-- you
know, the programs that we're
trying to do here at Google,
there's a lot of overlap,
a lot of similarity.
And yet one of the challenges
we face, especially
in places like LA, as
you mentioned-- we do
have an LA office,
the Bay Area--
is they don't want
to drive necessarily,
but then there's not a good
alternative for them, right?
So one of the challenges we face
is advocating for improvements
to the transportation
infrastructure.
What are some of your
thoughts about how to do that?
STANA KATIC: It comes down
to engaging with lawmakers.
But lawmakers have a
tough go, because they
have to answer to a bunch
of different parties.
And one of the biggest
elements that lawmakers
are responsible
for is maintaining
the economics of a town.
So businesses play a big role.
And sometimes what
we've found is
that businesses are concerned
that by having a bike
lane in front of
their storefront
they might lose foot
traffic, or they
might lose traffic in general.
And so what we are
trying to do right now
is we are meeting
with app developers
and trying to find the
right partnership to create
an app that would not just act
kind of like a map that gives
you the real time movement of
public transit in the area,
but it would also be a social
space where people could
discuss what bike lanes
look like at various points
of the day.
They can say, hey,
this intersection
is terrible between
noon and 2 o'clock.
Be careful there.
They can rate places
kind of like Waze does.
And we can also talk
about subway stops,
so that we can make the
infrastructure more-- we
can make it safer.
And in addition to
that, what we're
looking to do is by getting
the data and comparing it,
let's say, to the
improved economics,
because we have
statistics, but they're
scattered throughout the US.
By saying, hey,
businesses in Los Angeles,
businesses in San
Francisco, when
you have a bike lane in
front of your storefront,
you end up increasing
revenue by 179%, which
we saw in a Texas city, right?
So if we're able to give
them statistical proof,
and we're able to arm
government officials,
then they're going to be
able to go to businesses
and go to their constituency
and justify some of the improved
infrastructure.
And so that's where
we're at right now.
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
That's great.
So yeah, you're
talking about people
have barriers to using
alternate modes, right?
And so sometimes it actually
is the infrastructure.
Bike lanes is a great example.
And we've experienced that,
I know, in the Bay Area.
Probably in a lot
of our other offices
as well, where they'll build
this beautiful bike lane
and it goes right to
city limits, right?
And then there's no
cross-jurisdictional
coordination.
Do you see there being a
role in the use of technology
as one good example?
Are there other roles
where we can advocate
for that kind of
cross-jurisdictional or
regional mindset to
improve transportation
on a wider basis?
STANA KATIC: Yeah.
I mean, I think it's going to
come down to arming lawmakers
with what they need in order
to build the infrastructure.
It comes down to us
advocating for it.
It's simple economics--
supply and demand.
So if we demand it and if we're
using the infrastructure more,
than the government and
the institutions that
are responsible for
building projects like that,
they have no choice
but to supply it.
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
That's great.
So that's on the technology and
kind of infrastructure side.
A lot of your presentation--
which I think is fantastic--
is more about encouraging
people's behavior change,
right?
STANA KATIC: Right.
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
So it's one thing
to have the
infrastructure, but it's
another thing to just kind
of get over that hump.
One thing that we talked about
before, we like to illustrate
is, for bicycling, for instance.
There's people that
already bike to work.
And that's great.
And we want you to
keep doing that.
And then there's
people who are never
going to bike no matter what.
We'll just leave
you alone, right.
But there's that middle
group of, you know, I
might be willing to bike.
But there's something about
it that I'm not sure about.
STANA KATIC: Huge group.
It's like 60% of
cyclists [INAUDIBLE].
BRENDON HARRINGTON: So what are
some strategies that you think,
or you've seen that are
most important for us
to kind of consider as we
influence that group to change
their behavior.
STANA KATIC: Well, we know that
safety is an important one.
So you're looking at
the first and last mile.
And again, it has to do
with building infrastructure
and making the roadways safe.
And it's not just about
educating cyclists.
It's also about
educating car drivers.
Drivers.
So Long Beach is
doing a great job
of building a lot of
bicycle infrastructure.
And one of the things
that they've done
is they've slowly
educated the car community
about the new bike
infrastructure.
And they built these
really bold green lanes
so that there's no
way you can miss it.
So before bikes are
even put on the streets,
cars are getting
accustomed to the new ways
around town, and how to
be protective of cyclists.
So I think that's part of it.
I think starting
young too, if you
can find a way of
getting families
to travel alternatively, then
it becomes a part of the norm.
There's no reason
for us in the-- we're
in the 21st century.
This stuff should be
kind of like a no-brainer
at this point.
It's beneficial for your
health, for the environment,
and I think even for
a social experience.
It makes spaces safer.
So with that in mind, if
we can encourage children
to think of this as
normal, then we're
going to create adults who will
have their own families who
will do this kind of
activity regularly,
and who will demand that
out of their own towns
and out of their own experience.
And then we've got millennials.
I could talk about this forever.
Sorry.
But millennials are
changing it as well.
You know.
They're demanding more out
of their life experience.
They want to be able to
have time to socialize.
And they aren't necessarily
investing in cars
like previous generations have.
They're investing in
the next and best cell
phone, the next and best
laptop, the next best
whatever technology.
And they're enjoying that
on subways and on buses.
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
More so than trying
to buy a car and the house
that comes along with that.
STANA KATIC: Yes.
BRENDON HARRINGTON: How
about looking forward?
I mean, the future
of transportation.
I mean, are you optimistic?
What things do you
see are opportunities?
Where you see a role for
companies like Google
to kind of really think
about future transportation?
STANA KATIC: You're doing
a fantastic job right now.
Like I said, we're
exporting a lifestyle.
And Google is a
part of a messaging
that infiltrates everything,
every part of the globe.
And I saw that personally
when I was in Mongolia.
I'm not trying to do an
advertisement for Mongolia.
But what I am trying
to say is that even
in the most remote or
seemingly untouched landscapes,
the messages that we create
here are reverberating.
So when we say in
some of our models,
hey, this is a cool
way to live, then
people want to emulate that.
And it's really
difficult to say,
this is a cool way to live
if our story tellers are only
experiencing car culture.
Now if, as you guys are building
programs and apps and websites
and new technology, if
you were saying, hey,
car culture, biking is a
really cool way to live.
You might influence
people's choices next.
And I think that that's
a part of our future.
Did I make sense?
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
And I see you're
starting to talk about
a role for Google.
I mean, what can we do?
Either the Google's
transportation team
or Google in general.
What are some
opportunities you see
for us to be able to partner
with some of the messages
that you're getting out there.
STANA KATIC: I think use it.
If I can convince
one of you guys--
you're probably all
cyclists here anyway.
But if I can convince
someone who's not to try it,
and it affects you positively,
and you share your story
with other people,
it's going to translate
into more people doing it.
So I think by Googlers using the
infrastructure that you already
have, you're increasing the
demand for that infrastructure.
And you're going to be a
model-- a company model--
that we can export to
other parts of the planet.
And then you're also
going to build statistics.
And people need statistics.
And those statistics
should be free,
because they make
our world better.
And there's no reason for us
to monetize those statistics.
We can monetize other
things, because I
know everyone always thinks
about how to monetize stuff.
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
The behavior change
is something that we're
always looking for new angles.
We've been able to do
pretty well here at Google.
But we always think
we could do more.
And so as we learn about how
to translate the behavior
change along with the
infrastructure advocacy,
along with the apps
and technology,
it needs to be a
multi-faceted approach.
STANA KATIC: But what motivates
people really, in the end?
OK, it's finances.
And a lot of
governments work just
on increasing taxes
on this, and so on.
But it's also a
social experience.
If people believe that oh,
this is going to be fun.
This will be a really wonderful
thing to be a part of,
then they'll try it for a day.
We have events that are
like Midnight Ridazz.
And that encourages people
to just troll around
Los Angeles at midnight
with music blaring.
And it's this pack of cyclists.
And it's fun.
And it starts introducing
people to the concept
of being able to get
around town outside
of the bubble of their cars.
So you can create those
social experiences as well.
And then sometimes
it just comes down
to graphing a friend who
might not be a cyclist,
or might not be a
walker, and saying,
just walk with me to work.
Let's just walk together.
And introducing them
to how easy it is.
And just introducing
them to the tap card,
introducing them to
the stops, and so on.
Sometimes it's a little
bit of handholding.
BRENDON HARRINGTON: Yeah.
Good.
First live question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Big fan of Kate Beckett.
STANA KATIC: Thank you.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Ravi.
STANA KATIC: Ravish?
STANA KATIC: Ravi.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So you mentioned urbanization
and city planning.
One of the things that
has been happening,
especially in
developing countries,
is as cities grow frantically,
most of the planning
goes into building roads.
And houses tend to
cluster together,
places where people stay.
And offices are
usually far away.
So cycling and
walking, they're out
of the reach for those kind
of transportation modes.
So what do you think can
be done for future cities
right at the level
of city planning,
to make sure it's
really planned according
to keeping the environment and
transportation of these forms
in mind?
STANA KATIC: Well, of course,
we got subways and bus
systems that will be helpful.
I think it's a matter of
educating the leadership
in those countries.
In the case of Mon--
back to Mongolia.
Sorry.
But in the case of Mongolia,
a lot of their leadership
were recently nomads.
And so the concept
of public transit
and of protecting that
future for the people
was kind of remote
for people who
were used to traveling by
horseback for miles and miles.
So I think it
requires education.
And it's just a demand
factor, as well,
by your local populace.
You have to demand
that infrastructure.
This is the thing, too.
If we're doing it
here, they're going
to want to do it
everywhere else.
So countries that are in
development, countries that
are transitioning from let's
say, communism into capitalism,
we're the model, sometimes.
And this organization and this
company is a brilliant model.
Everybody wants to be this.
You know?
So we're exporting that.
And I think that's a part
of the process as well.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRENDON HARRINGTON: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Salim.
STANA KATIC: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So you're
in the movie industry.
But as you mentioned
earlier, cars
are romanticized in the movies.
And yes, you're kind
of exporting culture
from the movies and TV
shows internationally.
And we don't see European movies
where they're using the subway.
So that's not being
exported here.
Like we've got BART
where it doesn't really
stop anywhere over here, right?
And it's hard to retrofit.
Like where are
offices in San Paolo,
they just have bus service,
even though they have a subway.
You know it's difficult
to put that in.
So just, in movies,
are you trying
to change scripts
to get them to have
you use the subway in a scene?
Or riding a bike?
I've seen your show.
But I haven't seen
you on a bicycle.
STANA KATIC: No.
Not yet.
But it is something that becomes
part of the conversation.
I've joined one of
the media groups
that's responsible for
environmental messaging.
And so these are part of
people's thought process.
Oh, one thing I
want to say, if you
could get someone
like Tom Cruise
to ride the subway in
India, everybody, I think,
would want to value
that, and would make it
an investment, right?
So if you can get
people that are
in the public eye
and beloved, that's
a way also of focusing
people on that resource.
That being said, I
do have sometimes
a limited amount of influence.
And sometimes I'm
able to encourage
them to tell a story
that will shift us away
from a car-centric culture.
And I try.
And I think that we are
having more and more success
as we move forward.
But the biggest difficulty
is that if the writers aren't
riding subways and
aren't riding buses,
it's not the first thing
that comes to mind.
This is all secondary.
Transit is really secondary.
They just write it
in a car because it's
subconscious in a way.
We are inspired by
our surroundings.
We are inspired by our
relationships with people.
And if we build
the infrastructure,
that will affect the
change in storytelling.
Now we're conscious of it here.
So when you guys are
building your stories
that you're going to
export internationally,
maybe tomorrow you
can change the story
instead of being in a car,
the guy was on a bicycle
and he met her on a bicycle.
It could be part of
a conscious decision.
I feel like I kind of
like circled around and--
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STANA KATIC: Yeah.
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
Other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi Stana.
My name is Sakura.
And lately there's been a
lot of pieces and articles
on NPR and elsewhere about
infrastructure, especially
in the US, and how
our infrastructure
does not match up
with even developing
worlds' infrastructure.
There was a piece
on "The Daily Show"
comparing ours with South
Africa's infrastructure--
highways, et cetera.
And I was wondering,
there was also
a piece on NPR about how
that part of the freeway
hasn't been built. And it's been
in debate for about 50 years
in LA.
And so I was wondering from
just like an infrastructure
perspective, your experiences
in Mongolia and elsewhere
compared to what you've
seen being developed or not
happening in LA on the
infrastructure side,
or just like highways or
public transportation,
how have you seen LA evolve,
or maybe devolve, based
on your experience?
STANA KATIC: I found
it really interesting
when I first moved to LA.
I found it a little
difficult. Because I
was living in Chicago,
I was living in Toronto,
I had traveled to Europe.
And the concept of having
a center where everyone
goes to party was normal.
And the concept of getting on
a subway and heading somewhere
was normal in major
cities across the rest
of the US and the globe.
But that didn't feel like it
was the case in Los Angeles.
And because I was in a
car so much of the time
when I first arrived
in Los Angeles,
Los Angeles felt
really unconquerable.
Not in the way that oh,
you're beating something down.
In the way that you feel home.
You know?
I didn't feel like I had
access to other people
that were living in the city.
And I didn't feel
like I had access
to the heartbeat or
the rhythm of the city,
because I was stuck in
the bubble of my car.
And I said, oh, you know what?
One day, if I have
a voice that's
large enough, that can
reach enough people,
I'd like to try to change it.
Because I believe that
this is a media capital.
And I think it'll affect
everything else out there.
And LA has had horrible
experiences with smog,
and has worked really
hard to shift that.
And it didn't make sense to
me either, because I said,
this is California.
We're supposed to be
environmentally progressive.
That's what everyone else says.
Right?
And a huge amount of the US GDP
circulates through this state,
possibly still more so
than any other state.
So shouldn't this feel
be like a no-brainer?
Anyway.
Over the years that's changed.
LA has started investing-- and
it likely was the whole time.
I just wasn't as aware
of it as I am now,
because I have
actively sought it out.
And because I think that
their voice-- Metro's voice,
LADOT's voice-- is getting
louder, because millennials
don't want to sit in a car
for three hours in a day
to get somewhere, to get
to work and get home.
They want to just be able to pop
on the subway, listen to music,
read a book, and like,
chat with friends, right?
So I think that there is a
youth culture in Los Angeles,
there is a creative force
in Los Angeles that's
demanding more
out of their life,
and is asking the
city to develop more.
I think that people are becoming
more environmentally conscious.
I think that there's a shift
in attitudes and behavior.
I mean, there are a
ton of electric cars
that are forcing
people, in a way,
or making people question
how do we get around
from place to place
in a way that we
haven't had to years before?
I'm going on.
I know.
Anyway.
I think there's an improvement
happening in Los Angeles.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: To follow that
up there, I just watched
a video on YouTube about
how Heineken is sponsoring
some type of musical turnstiles,
which a guy had an idea about,
and to build that into the
New York subway system.
And so I was
wondering if you are
aware of any such
things happening
in LA's transportation
system to not just improve
the basic infrastructure, but
to make the commute more fun.
For me, that means
even though I ride
my car, that means just
plugging in my music in the car
so that the commute, if
I'm stuck in traffic,
passes by faster.
The Google shuttles are
very helpful in that we
have Wi-Fi on there, and
so that we can do work.
But I was wondering
for public transit,
how do we make it
more fun so that we
can inspire more people?
STANA KATIC: I
think you're right.
I think we can have events
on the subway system.
We could have a party train.
Why not?
There could be a music system
that's playing on a train.
Once in awhile.
And it wouldn't distract
other commuters.
I think that would be a really
great way of encouraging people
to come and seeing they're
transit in a different light.
Also, the way that
we decorate-- it
sounds kind of frou frou-- but
the way we decorate our stops
can be quite inspiring.
Los Angeles is doing a
great job of coordinating
with local artists and
making the stops special,
and each of them tell
a different story.
And then there is development
that is encouraging businesses
on each space.
So bringing in
great restaurants,
great cafes, that you can have
a social experience at a stop
is really important,
I think, for people.
And it changes the face and
the way that you see travel.
Travel can be fun.
I've seen other companies do it.
I've seen Virgin
make travel fun.
I love watching that video
in all versions of it.
And we can do that
to public transit.
And maybe it requires
partnering up
with a really great
private organization.
BRENDON HARRINGTON: Thank you.
We'll take another
live question.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Stana.
My name's Nick.
STANA KATIC: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So Google is
obviously willing to invest--
STANA KATIC: You
look like an actor.
AUDIENCE: Is that a uh--
invitation for a cameo
on "Castle"?
STANA KATIC: Go ahead, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So Google is
obviously willing to invest
a ton of money in
moonshot ideas,
like stuff that sounds crazy or
is super risky, but also really
ambitious.
And an example is
the self-driving car.
And I work next to these guys.
And it's really
amazing what they're
doing-- making cars safer so
more people will hopefully
be willing to bike some day.
But if you were
the CEO of Google,
was there a kind of wild
mode of transportation
you would have us invent
to help ATP's cause?
STANA KATIC: You mean
other than my jet pack?
AUDIENCE: Hey.
That's good.
STANA KATIC: OK.
We'll start with the jet pack.
I'd like to partner with
someone on this app.
I really think that
by giving governments
the statistics they need, they
can change the infrastructure.
And we can create safe
spaces across the globe.
I'd like to see a great
bike lane along the coast
from San Francisco down to LA.
Those are just a couple.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Well, hopefully the
right person's listening.
STANA KATIC: Yeah.
Thank you.
BRENDON HARRINGTON: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Stana.
My name is Mani.
STANA KATIC: Hi.
AUDIENCE: My question
is more around
there are a lot of
initiatives here right
now about making people use
bikes and things like that.
But it's mostly one
day of the year,
like, bike to work
and things like that.
But how do you make
these people use
these bikes or other means of
transportation more regularly?
Because we bike one day.
And then, we forget again.
It's only one-day rotation.
So how to make it
more like a habit,
so that people do
this more often.
STANA KATIC: Well, I
think you start there.
You start with one day a year.
Another stat-- if everyone
went car-free for just one day,
we'd be saving 11 billion trees.
So just starting
there is effective.
We have a great organization
called CicLAvia.
One of our board
member actually,
is a part of CicLAvia.
And they started with
just a few events.
And slowly it's grown.
And so let's start there.
Let's just encourage people to
go biking one day in a year.
And then let's do it
a couple more times.
Let's set up a couple of events.
Let's grab friends together
and say hey, let's just bike
together.
There are different
challenges you can create.
But if you start
with the one day,
that's a step in
the right direction.
What are your thoughts?
AUDIENCE: I mean,
I think it should
be more of a social experience.
You know, that's
where enough people--
other companies and
other initiatives
try to include more people
habitate-- or make it a habit
is maybe more of a
social experience.
I kind of don't see
that a lot happening.
You talk about a lot of things
like partying and things
like that.
But I think that it has to be
more of a social experience.
STANA KATIC: So you're
thinking of making it
more of a social
experience here at Google.
Maybe getting a midnight
ride as sort of experience
here at Google.
That cold be fun.
AUDIENCE: Everything's open.
STANA KATIC: Yeah.
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
That's great.
We'll be able to
take a couple more.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Stana.
I'm Russell.
STANA KATIC: Hi, Russell.
AUDIENCE: I don't really have
a really focused question.
But one area that--
STANA KATIC: It's OK.
I've been unfocused
the entire time.
AUDIENCE: When people
choose to drive,
it's mostly because
it's convenient.
And one of the most important
factors is time, right?
So as cities get more crowded,
it takes longer and longer
to drive.
And for me, I actually bike.
And I can actually bike
as fast as I can drive,
with a lot more reliability too.
There's no traffic
to worry about.
Have you looked
into stats where you
might find that walking or
driving or taking the bus
is actually faster than driving?
Because that's what people
care about on some level.
STANA KATIC: Well, yeah.
What we do is we
say, oh, how long
does it take me to
get from here to work?
And it's different for
everyone, of course.
And sometimes it's
faster if you go by bike.
Sometimes it's faster
if you go by car.
But then, let's look at
the other things as well.
I want to be fit.
I want to look
handsome for my partner
or for my future
spouse or whatever.
So I know I'm going to be
spending an hour every day
at the gym.
Well, that adds extra time.
But you can kill two
birds with one stone
if you just ride your
bike to work, right?
So I think that there
is a lot of stuff
to take in consideration in
order to motivate a person.
And I think that's
what you're asking
is, how do we motivate
people to take
an alternative mode of transit.
And if it comes down
to time and just time,
then things like that.
You can collaborate efforts.
You can say, hey, man.
You don't have to work
out today because you just
rode your bike to work.
You know?
AUDIENCE: And you don't
have to spend time parking.
I mean, people ignore--
STANA KATIC: That's
extra time, as well.
I'm sure that there's a billion
ideas about how this would
save people time in the end.
I know I have friends
in Los Angeles who
have made the choice
to cycle only to work.
And they found
that after a while,
they were able to get
to work in 45 minutes.
For instance, I
have a colleague who
gets to work on his
bike in 45 minutes.
And he's timed it out regularly.
And he said, it takes me an
hour and four minutes to drive.
So you know.
You've got to also
test it out sometimes.
Thanks, Russell.
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
We'll take the last two,
and then we'll wrap up.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for stopping by.
I had a question about NIMBYism,
both in like the community
level and just like in
the sense of planning.
Like to get to the LA
airport, you can theoretically
take the new subway
line they're building up
until a certain point.
SFO, you have to change
trains several times.
Communities are just like voting
out of public transportation.
Like even the BART
expansion in the Bay Area.
Like, what can we
do to get everyone
on board for the
greater good, instead
of these little fiefdoms that
just vote themselves out?
STANA KATIC: You have
to talk to people.
You have to engage with them.
You have to bring
real statistics.
I sit down with
people all the time
who don't have the
complete picture about how
it could benefit them.
So it's a matter of educating
people and being patient
and continuing to advocate in
spite of those steps backward.
I don't know.
What do you think?
You've got experience, it seems.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Regional planning is probably
the best way to go about it.
Like, some sort of a regional
Transportation Authority
with real power to zone
and implement I guess.
At least in the Bay Area.
That's my opinion.
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
So to wrap up,
thank you so much for your time.
Thank you for sharing
your thoughts.
There's lots of themes here.
There's the infrastructure
improvements.
There's behavior change.
There's advocacy.
And then there's this
use of technology.
And then most importantly,
is the communications and use
of the media.
So thanks for sharing all that.
We hope we can continue
to work together.
STANA KATIC: Thank you.
BRENDON HARRINGTON:
And thank you all.
Please join me in thanking
Stana for her time.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]